si je vous dis carbapénémases génotypage
ou encore qu remy bactéries vous
répondez vous n'avez pas compris c'est
bien normal
pourtant dans les années 50 la science
était présente à la télévision c'était
une volonté du gouvernement
un défi de taille car seuls 10% des
français avaient un téléviseur en 1959
d'ailleurs les missions médicales une
des premières émissions scientifiques
montré une crises convulsives chez un
lapin pourrait donc faire passer un choc
électrique et vous allez voir l'animal
qui présente immédiatement une crise
convulsive je résume donc un choc
électrique un lapin cela donne une crise
convulsive le but ici est de vulgariser
la science mais au fait ça veut dire
quoi exactement
la vulgarisation scientifique est
importante bulgarie gré c'est-à-dire de
rendre vulgaire ce qui est compliqué et
faire en sorte que les gens croient pas
que la science c'est en temps dehors de
leurs possibilités de compréhension
le message est clair que chaque
téléspectateur comprennent la science et
les styles des missions sont divers vous
avez tout simplement l'émission
soporifique
alors voici un contour et voici un
élément marqué par un point et que
j'appelle x et il est à l'intérieur du
contour c'est à dire tu as we expliqué
le théorème de bâches et des hutus de
tchaïkovski à la télévision ça peut vite
devenir ennuyeux mais ne vous inquiétez
pas il y en a pour tout le monde
vous avez le choix entre construire le
réacteur d'une fusée pour vous donner
une idée de ce qui se passe à l'arrière
d'une fusée je m'en vais ajouter cet
oxygène liquide amont combustible ou
bien encore assister le professeur
delmas pour disséquer un sérieux et
maintenant je peux tirer est amené à moi
l'ensemble même de toute la masse on
céphalique découper un cerveau assisté
aux premiers pas de l'homme sur la lune
la télévision est un moyen comme un
autre pour apprendre et dans les années
80 les émissions scientifiques se font
rare à l'écran
pourtant un homme va tenter de relancer
le genre hubert curien ministre de la
recherche de la technologie
je pense que tous ces efforts qui sont
faits maintenant un peu partout et tout
spécialement ici à marseille pour rendre
tout à fait accessibles des notions
scientifiques à très large public était
indispensable
peine perdue pour ministre gray
l'arrivée de égale m6 en 1991 et de
c'est pas sorcier en 1993 le nombre des
missions scientifiques diffusé à la
télévision ne cesse de chuter
malgré un léger sursaut à la fin des
années 2000
le constat est simple en 1995 661
magazine scientifique était diffusé sur
les six premières chaînes contre
seulement 186 en 2017
[Musique]